[Music]
welcome my name is will i'm one of the
admission officers here at stanford
graduate school of business over the
course of today's event we are going to
be talking a little bit not just about
the experience itself um and hearing
from the folks who just went through it
but one of the questions i often get is
hey what is that return on investment
look like and so
recognizing that
return on investment is going to look
very different for different people it's
also going to look different based on
the life stage and that career stage
that you might be at and so the next few
weeks many of our events are geared
towards helping us like identify and
define and articulate some of the
different ways the gsb experience can
help you both immediately out of um the
business school experience through your
career you know five years as a seasoned
leader
and what could that look like for you in
that long term that long-term story of
your personal narrative
so today we'll be focusing a lot on that
immediate after the few years after you
graduate so we'll meet our uh panelists
i have a few warm-up questions and then
we'll turn solely to that q a box and
really try to answer as many questions
as we can
we'll have about 55 minutes together um
and so let's go ahead and meet our
panelists
oh actually just a quick
backdrop over 30 000 alumni around the
world um organized into 60 alumni
chapters so really great ways for you to
if you're exploring different places of
the world if you're thinking about
different interest areas ways to stay
connected and continue to make use of
the gsb resources
even in the beyond
women's chapters diversity chapters you
can even stay in contact with our career
services our cmc that career management
center they continue to provide services
and programs for alumni and we love the
involvement think of that one year
five-year tenure ten-year reunion
always amazing times on campus
so now let's get to our panelists
if we can go uh left to right so sean
may be starting with you if you could
tell us a little bit about um yourself
and let's just knock it out of the park
now what was your favorite course or
what was the most valuable course that
you took while at the gsb
yeah
sure of course thanks will hi everyone
my name's sean deville i'm class of 2019
um so graduated a few years ago um i i
come from a fairly traditional business
background and i did two years of
investment banking and a couple years of
private equity before going to stanford
and then i actually returned to the
private equity firm um
after business school uh and and do tech
investing where i've done there for for
several years um
my favorite course at stanford was a
class called leadership perspectives
um which which was this really
interesting course where you know you
meet twice a week and and the first
session of each week would basically be
a
you know high-powered ceo or senior
person at an investment firm or um an
entrepreneur
um and and it would basically be
unscripted and unfiltered sort of q a
between the class and that person and it
would kind of go into you know
a bunch of different areas religion
work-life balance
um marriage career career paths how to
juggle
um you know two different career
opportunities um and i i thought that
part was fascinating because you get to
hear it straight from them
um
and and particularly around work-life
balance and what it means to have you
know a two-career
um marriage or or family um
and then the second session of that week
would basically be you meet with the
same four or five classmates and you
discuss you know what did you hear in
that session with with that leader and
and how do you feel about it do you
agree do you disagree um and so there's
a lot of you know comparing and
contrasting between week to week and you
really got to know those four or five
classmates very well who um
i think we're sort of in the same boat
as you know they're interested in what
it means to to do some of these things
and think about these things
thoughtfully but also they have
different perspectives so i thought it
was a great class
john was there a particular
topic or um
without necessarily going to the speaker
if the content was um sensitive but was
there a particular thing that y'all um
kind of debated or was an aha moment a
learning moment that you found really
powerful from that course
yeah so so one um
it was interesting
in that maybe
60 or 75 of the speakers were divorced
or had been divorced
and a lot of them talked about how
work-life balance just could not work
for them
um and and they went through all the
reasons why um and so what we we
discussed as classmates and as peers you
know how much does work-life balance
mean to you and and what does that mean
and then with one of the speakers one of
the few who um had been married for
20-plus years what he the way he
described it and what we all you know
resonated with us and we all agreed with
was um here are all the things this is
basically like a list of questions that
he wished he knew
um the answer to or had spoken to with
his partner before they got married you
know you know how much is too much
traveling you know if one career is
taking off and does the other person
take a step back like getting this you
know very specific and explicit yes no
um kind of question and answers with
with the partner is that like a really
interesting exercise that at least me
and
me and
three of my five classmates um in my
group we had not done explicitly um with
our kind of long-term partners so it was
a little thought exercise like that
primarily centered around work-life
balance i thought were uh fascinating
yeah we often talk a lot about the
career and here's where you're gonna go
next but thinking about those life
adjacent things that often inform kind
of how you approach the life after like
thank you
all right song welcome if you could tell
us a little bit about yourself and what
was a memorable or valuable class that
you took while at the gsb
sure so my name is song i graduated uh
in this past year with khalil and well
not this past year the the 2020 with
khalil and before gsb i had worked in
both tech as well as venture capital and
during the gsb made a career switch to
work in investment management
which more basically means i research uh
different companies that have stocks and
decide whether or not we should be
investing in them and so when i think
about my favorite class
you know the one that really stands out
to me is actually a class that i took
about how to incorporate different
religious beliefs and spiritual beliefs
into your leadership style and into your
work
professionally and this class was taught
by the former dean of religious life at
all of stanford and every week we'd kind
of sit in a circle
and the first part of the class you know
similar to what sean said there would be
a prominent business leader like the ceo
of linkedin or the ceo of you know all
these different companies that um
either followed or practiced a
particular type of spiritual belief and
you know that person would come in talk
about how their
you know experience influenced their
leadership style influence how they ran
their company and how they set culture
and made decisions and then afterwards
we would have this you know very active
debate about what constitutes you know
privacy or boundaries but what
constitutes like leadership and culture
and that was a class that had a really
profound impact on me personally because
like sean said you know these are things
that you think you know until
you know a question gets posed by one of
your classmates and you realize you
don't know you know at all how you would
have handled the situation or how you
would answer it um so that class really
you know made a big impact on me
yeah is there i and this is out of
curiosity from my friend and it might be
have been in your rear rear view mirror
to some degree but was there a question
in particular that you found really
striking that you that you might
remember
yeah i think you know
every class inevitably you know
kind of meander to the question of
what is the responsibility of a business
leader is it to maximize profits is it
to build an enduring
company with a very strong culture is it
to take care of your employees is it to
put your customers first and you can
easily see how depending on what kind of
business you're in
those questions can become very uh
complicated very quickly and so i think
that's probably what
i constantly left i walked out of every
class kind of grappling with that kind
of decision of like what really is my
responsibility as a leader um you know
to my colleagues to my manager to my
customers to you know everyone
else
nice thank you khalil can you tell us a
little bit about yourself and what uh
of course that really stuck out to you
uh yeah for sure um
uh so that song mentioned i graduated in
2020 um prior to the gsb i i went to
amherst for undergrad and spent my
pre-gsb career in marketing research and
strategy roles so
mainly on the agency side then i worked
in brand and innovation consulting
as well
um helping focus on how do we think
about positioning brands and then how do
we launch physical mainly physical cpg
products um into market
i went to gsb uh now work at facebook
i'm a product marketing manager which
basically means it's a mix of marketing
business strategy and product strategy
of um helping um determine what types of
products we should build
um and then on the outbound marketing
piece of like how do we talk and
position those those products to to
customers
um my favorite class at the gsp that's
tough
uh i
i
i i'll say
i'm gonna give i'm gonna say two
actually on the front soft skills with
some cheating so in soft skills i would
say touchy feely i think everyone will
tell you that that's an incredible class
but uh i i think for a lot of reasons
that that class kind of changed both how
i interact in business settings but also
with a lot of my personal relationships
as well um and and that's a class that
you sit in a circle with 13 other people
and you talk about your feelings for
hours like many hours
out of time um and then
um
on the opposite end i i would say the
industrialist dilemma um taught by rob
segal
you you meet with a lot of like c-suite
executives i met with the ceo of gsk ceo
of target um and really got to really
understand how they think about about
their business as well
and how how do you think about the
industrialist dilemma like how would you
encapsulate that in like a few words not
that it that would be easy at all but
um yeah i think
it the the class just really talks about
all of you go through different problems
that um a business um can face so for
example with target uh we talked about
okay
amazon's entering the market how do you
ha like how do you grow your business
when they're in when there's disruption
happening all around you um and then we
brainstorm
ideas of how we would do it often we
were completely wrong um and then the
then the ceo would come and talk about
how they thought about it um so i think
it's really different for for
um each business but it's really about
how do you
how does your
business adapt and stay agile
when there are a bunch of different
pressures coming from like investors or
your your internal employees consumers
um to to ultimately make the best
decision for for your business
nice
all right ryan
class of 21.
can you tell us a little bit about
yourself and
in this like short window looking back
favorite class
yeah it feels a little bit surreal to be
on an uh alumni panel because it was
literally weeks ago that i was a student
so that's fun for me i guess
um but yeah my name is brian
i literally just graduated in june
and uh now working on a startup venture
uh based in san francisco
yeah favorite class i will follow khalil
and say that um
interpersonal dynamics also known as
touchy feely is a terrific course and
then uh i'll also add startup garage
which was a great great class for me is
one of the classes that my partner and i
use to launch our business
so i have to have positive feelings
about startup garage as well but
basically if you're not familiar with it
it's an experiential class
so you um
you're working on a specific
venture idea and then you have advisors
around you
and throughout a structured program
you're testing the resonance of your
idea with
uh potential customers and you're
building prototypes of your business so
it's kind of a fun hands-on way to test
entrepreneurship before you know
graduating school
oh brian can you tell us a little bit
more about um sorry garage there's a lot
of questions that i frequently get about
it like what kinds of mentorship happen
do
folks actually get funded out of it how
do you find a partner going into it like
or a group like can you give a little
bit of flavor about any any of those
questions i just kind of threw at you
yeah sure um
so i'll start with forming a group
that's a big thing that happens on at
school
um i don't think there's one way to form
a group people you know they have
someone they knew in a prior life
and you're allowed to have other people
on your team as long as you have
stanford people on your team it could be
classmates in the mba program it could
be stanford people in other graduate
schools that aren't business you know
programs so people have all sorts of
ways that they uh match up on teams for
me
uh i matched up with uh someone else in
the business school in the mba program
so we work together as a pair
um and then in terms of how the program
works so it's a two-quarter program
and you have a dedicated advisor each
time
uh and this is someone you weak oh my
computer's reacting this is someone you
work with on a
weekly basis and then you also have
uh other supporting advisors that you
work with in total i think there's more
than like 10 faculty people who are part
of the startup garage program
and then lastly on funding
people do get funded
i don't know the statistics but my
partner and i were funded and i think
many other people in our class were
funded so it is a pass if you want it to
be to full-time entrepreneurship
thank you ryan and also welcome to
alumni hood
i think there are two journeys that i
hear a lot about so sean will be
starting with you on
you came from pe you went back how do
you think about the value of the mba and
like
like why do an mba if you're going to
return if you're thinking about
returning and then for folks who might
have pivoted or did a little exploration
i'll be coming to that that side of the
equation next so maybe sean if you can
get us kicked us off um from sonia
for those going back to the same job
industry employer what was the biggest
takeaway from stanford gsb since since
it wasn't a career pivot
yeah
that's a great question um and and i
actually when i was in michigan
undergrad i was actually in the
undergraduate business school there too
so
folks were really asking me why am i
going back and getting an mba
and the way i thought about it was sort
of twofold so
um going to business school versus not
and then you know why stanford business
school versus any other business school
so on the first part of that question i
think the biggest thing for me was
network um you know not only within the
folks in your class but also
you know the full alumni um network that
you get
access to and really becomes
incredibly supportive from day one um
that kind of gsb offers um i think
that's probably number one number two
was
um
for my peers who are also in private
equity or going back into the industry
or the sector that that i also work in
and was going back and back to you can
kind of see how
their firms you know looked at the world
they thought about investments and you
pick their brand they pick yours and
it's kind of a you know um
a good learning experience from that
perspective and that you can see the
landscape a little bit better than when
you did when you're just within your own
firm or your own group in private equity
and then the third thing which kind of
is a good segue into standard stanford
versus other business schools is is the
curriculum outside of what i would call
the core business classes so you know i
wasn't going to stand for getting an mba
to you know learn accounting or take a
marketing course it was more about the
soft skills and i think that's where
stanford you know really shines um i
think a lot of folks go to business
school and you know they want to learn
how to become a ceo um i was more
interested in
you know what you need to do and what do
you need to learn to become a leader and
i think that's where stanford really
shines um and you know we've walked
through some of those classes already
and i'm happy to highlight a few more um
and then the last thing for me
specifically is you know i i invest
specifically in technology and stanford
being right in palo alto and so close to
san francisco and san jose you're you're
kind of in the epicenter of technology
so um the way that you know i guess
reflects itself is one all a lot of
speakers who are in the area this is
pre-co bid would come to the classroom
and you can build those relationships
not even within just within those 45
minute sessions or however long but you
know after class and and follow-ups um
and then second is there's a bunch of
career tracks and kind of club tracks
where you'll just go explore the area um
so kind of being in this community uh
was it was a big pull for me for
stanford specifically so i hope that
answers the question
yeah i did thank you and we'll actually
come back to some of those other like
leadership development courses and
lessons from there because i see a
number of questions in the q a box so
hot topic so we'll definitely get there
for our other panelists whether it was a
small pivot or a larger pivot can you
talk about how stanford helped you along
that journey even if it was just a
little bit of exploration um
can anybody
shed a little bit of light there
sure i can jump in so i actually
was
99.9 percent sure i was going to go back
into venture capital or or at least like
a startup i had been living in the bay
area and i loved the whole ecosystem
and so when i got to stanford
i
um
just wanted to experiment and try
different things and so it was one of
these experiments that actually led me
to discover this other area within
financial services but you know
completely different type of work
and it was kind of like you know one
coffee chat led to one interview led to
one internship and then before i knew it
i kind of
walked down this other path and you know
found something that was much better
suited for me um so i would say you know
even if you you are you know 99.9 sure
of something just opening yourself up to
exploration um
is really wonderful and gives you
chances to just learn things about
yourself even if you don't you know
change career paths
but i would say the other thing as well
is you just encounter so many
perspectives you encounter people from
so many different you know backgrounds
whether that's
places they grew up industries that they
worked with and so i would say like sean
alluded to this but even if you're going
back into a similar line of work or a
similar job you will learn so much about
the rest of the world and other
businesses that will you know only make
you more successful
yeah song i have a question you
mentioned from one conversation to an
interview um were these classmates where
these alumni how who are some of these
folks that kind of serendipitously led
led you on this journey
oh um you know it was a path with many
different mentors but i would say you
know it started with classmates just hey
what did you do before school why did
you like that why didn't you like that
oh this company is coming to campus
because we have a lot of alums and
they're going to come and talk about
their line of work um great they have a
formal internship program here's you
know let's assign you a mentor
what does it take to prepare for these
interviews and it kind of just you know
every step of the way i don't think it's
something i could have done without the
ecosystem
and that ecosystem is more about the
people
present students and alumni that kind of
come together to form that ecosystem
thank you yeah
and then brian there's a couple
questions here and i might extend this
after um your response did you know you
wanted to go into um entrepreneurship or
that that you were that you wanted to
start a company how did that happen
and then kind of at a broader level for
the other folks
how solid of an idea
did you have coming into business school
there's a question here about from
caroline
about how helpful the gsb was at helping
you identify your passion or the things
you wanted to do and so um i think we
might have alluded to a little bit there
but maybe let's start with you brian
like did you know you wanted to go into
this and then
we can blow up the conversation
yeah i
i
[Music]
kind of i started business school and
the goal in my heart was to start a
company one of the first classes i had
in the fall quarter
of my first year the teacher had us
write down in class what our
dream goal essentially was and that was
my goal so it was early on my goal was
to start a company but it was also
something that i was very afraid of and
i didn't know if i had what if i had
what it took i didn't have a specific
idea i didn't have a partner
i mean there were a lot of things that i
thought i didn't have that would keep me
from achieving that goal so it felt very
scary to me
um so
part of business school for me was was
really through a lot of ways building
the confidence that it's not such a
scary thing and that you can
de-risk and de-risk and de-risk by
making various decisions like who you
partner with and what you work on and
you know there's just stuff you can
start to do
um
and
that was really i think a two-year
process for me but i've reached the
ultimate point where
you know a few months before graduation
my partner and i were mentally prepared
to commit to each other and
you know to the rest of the people we
were working with that this is something
that we were really gonna dedicate
ourselves to and you know who knows if
it works out but it's we're gonna give
it everything we can and i think
stanford absolutely was a huge part
you know for me of building that
confidence and
gaining some tools along the way of how
to go about starting the company
nice i think khalil like
as you were at the gsb did you have a
clear thread of what you want to do or
was there exploration and how did you go
about identifying those things that were
meaningful for you in the career search
uh yeah i think i
new things i enjoyed i knew broadly
things that i enjoyed so i knew i
enjoyed marketing um i i knew i wanted
to be i was pretty sure i wanted to be
an operator and less play less of a
consultant role
um but outside of that i did i wasn't
really and i know i was interested in
technology so that's like one of the
main reasons why i chose gsb is because
um i knew i'd be surrounded uh in in
silicon valley um
i
but but i think being at the gsb
really opened my eyes to like all of the
different opportunities that were out
there um and
just just with classmates right even
just on this call there's so many people
with so many different backgrounds so
like i started off the gsb we're just
talking to a lot of people about what
they did before before business school
and trying to figure out if that's what
i would if that would be interesting to
me um even venture capital i was like oh
that seems cool like that like
there's
there's some marketing strategy there
there's some business strategy there um
but talking to someone i was like i
don't i don't know if that's like when i
really dug into it it really helped me
figure out that okay no
that wasn't the perfect spot for me at
this moment um so i think it really just
just being immersed by so many people as
a lot of people on this call mentioned
um was really really valuable
and um yeah and helped me
help solidify that product marketing was
a role that i i wanted to do post usb
nice i know there's a report that comes
out every year from our career
management center about the outcomes and
in that report they talk a little bit
about where these opportunities came
from i think the split was a third come
from uh
opportunities through the career
management center a third come from
uh students and alumni and another third
come from that might be self-source or
you know if they were sponsored and are
returning to their company from there
i'm curious
has anybody on this call worked with a
career management center or were you
representative of the other two-thirds
of the outcomes here
i i i definitely work with the career
management center
can you tell me uh talk a little bit
about um how they supported you through
that or
some insight into there
yeah so
i work pretty heavily with um
with grace
and gina who are just um
um
two of the faculty in the career center
they're both really great um they're
both kind of specialized in different
things so like um i spent a ton of time
with you on actual like prepping for for
actual interviews so we did case we
would go through outside of time we
would have 30 minutes to just talk
through their cases and then i use um
grace as
like my
like mentor of like what should i like
long term what should i be doing in my
life and how should i be thinking about
that um they've both been super valuable
and
yeah so
they've actually both of them have been
like instrumental in helping me
determine what role um
what role and what types of
companies i would want to work for
and brian i saw you smiling and nodding
as khalil was talking about some of the
folks he worked with were you able to
interact with anybody from the cmc
during your time
yeah i was smiling because i worked with
grace a lot too and i would totally
recommend her she's fantastic
um yeah i work with them less on a
full-time job but
um part of my my theory of testing
entrepreneurship was to see how i liked
working
in a non-financial services role which
is what i was previously doing
and so i used my summer between the
first and second year to do two
internships that were totally different
from finance one was at a health care
company doing product work and one was
at um
an e-commerce company doing strategy
work and those were just tests for me on
how i liked those types of different
roles um and grace was
invaluable towards thinking about you
know how i should pick those and figure
out companies that would be good fits
within that so they were they were very
helpful for me
career management center awesome people
i get to work on the floor with them
it's amazing anytime i get to interact
with them and talk about kind of how
they help support our community
and so we have we're going to shift
gears a little bit there's a question
here from nicole
um about if after graduation
if you could go back in time and start
the program all over again what advice
would you give yourself as an incoming
mba candidate usually i'll save a
question like this for the end but i'll
have a different um end question of kind
of to motivate us but as you think about
yourself
two three years ago
what advice would you give yourself as
an incoming mba candidate and open
anybody wants to start
i i i can start um
so
i actually got this advice from several
people but it's kind of hard to
contextualize it until you're at campus
but a lot really happens um in your
first quarter you know just school
social
um
sometimes even even the internship
recruiting and and i think the biggest
thing um that i wish i knew was you know
the ability to say no to things
and kind of defensive calendaring and
because i think folks will just fill up
your google calendar with stuff and you
want to go to everything truthfully
because it's a lot of fun and um
and it's just a little you can get a
little overwhelming at times you know
i
i consider myself like a fairly outgoing
person um but then when you meet
everyone at stanford everyone's dialed
it's like 12 out of 10 particularly in
the first quarter so you know it's fun
but it it feels a little crazy and you
know that that first quarter really asks
yourself well how did i get in here
because you're meeting so many amazing
people um that you know alone time
actually i think really really helps my
um
my
uh girlfriend at the time now fiance she
lives in san francisco and like one of
my favorite parts truthfully of the week
was whenever we go visit her because
it's an hour-long car ride to san
francisco and it was the one time where
you're not kind of surrounded by people
talking and
and i know a lot of folks got that
through through exercise or you know
meditation or other ways but i would
highly recommend it you know block off
time for yourself because uh
if you don't if you don't do it no one
else will
i love the phrase defensive calendaring
i think i'm gonna use that like all the
time now any tips for how people might
be able to defensively calendar
especially knowing like the gsb
environment
yeah i i i would just block off like 30
minutes to an hour every day um
whether it's a long stretch of class or
you know a bunch of back-to-back coffee
cats where you are kind of uh
you know
on with folks um that that's usually
when i would do it for the gym or for
you know for something read or a podcast
um i think i think he's plugging that in
and a lot of the settles too after the
first quarter
once everyone kind of gets a little bit
more comfortable with the environment
and themselves and their classmates but
it's that first quarter where it can
feel a little overwhelming
nice
so in addition to defensive calendaring
what other advice might
one of the other panelists give yourself
as an incoming mba candidate
yeah i think a lot of what sean says um
definitely resonates with me i
on that note of it being
super busy like you're going to
start day one and it's going to be crazy
busy with so many different things and
activities you can focus on and i've
never been busier in my entire life
there was like not there's
you don't have time to do everything so
you're going to have to prioritize
and i think having a clear mindset of
before
of what you want to get out of the
experience what you want to get out of
each whether you want to do it each year
each quarter
however you want to look at it but like
coming in with that and making sure that
how you split your time represents what
your priorities are is
in my perspective incredibly important
so that would be my advice it's like
figure out exactly what you want to get
out of there and make sure that your
time your energy is devoted in those
categories because it's like so easy to
get wrapped up in like everything else
that's going on um
and everything that's thrown at you like
social events as john mentioned like
there's gonna be so much in q1 but then
all of a sudden the first recruiting is
gonna be consult like consultant
recruiting is going to like come and
then you're going to be like should i be
a consultant and you're and it's like
you didn't want to be a consultant
before um but like everything gets like
it's so easy to get wrapped up in the
mix of like really having like a clear
vision of what you want
it's funny when
like everybody on the call kind of
laughs at something because that feeling
just kind of kicks back in as you were
talking about like oh consulting
recruiting starts do i want to be a
consultant i just saw a lot of phases
light up because apparently that thought
process very common
um
let's switch gears again i did promise
to talk about the leadership curriculum
and i and that's one of the things that
we hear a lot about on um our panel so
doris's question at the top about what
area of your leadership potential did
you feel had the greatest opportunity
for development and how did gsb help
fill those gaps strengthen those areas
so i'm gonna broaden this question a
little bit because i think coming into
business school
you might have thought about hey here's
an area that i would like to develop
but coming out of the experience
sometimes there's areas that you didn't
realize um
were opportunities for growth and those
were aha moments for you so
we'll open it up so
either
areas that you knew you wanted to
develop and how did you kind of target
that or hey realization of i did develop
great like greatly in this area and how
um so either
looking forward or looking back
um maybe brian because you have one of
the fresher experiences um can you get
us kicked off and then song will come to
you next
yeah um so
my answer when i
started at stamford when i applied i was
not i was focused on entrepreneurship
and i think exploring the world beyond
finance
um
but i wasn't focused on
the arbuckle leadership program but that
was something i ended up focusing on so
what that is it's a program that you
apply to in your first year and it's
focused on
communication with other people and how
groups work together and how teams work
together
and it's also i think focused on knowing
yourself and there's classes that are
directed towards
you're just getting a finer point on
what you value and why you value it and
how you want to manifest those things in
your life
um
and so as i started taking those classes
i i think i saw that i was taking a lot
out of it and that it was really
a period of a lot of personal growth for
me in terms of
um
just really being
for the first time in my life i think
rigorous about
what i was searching for and why
and how far i was willing to go to get
it and how i could really communicate
better because i think i was actually
fairly
fairly closed off in my communication
before business school
so
yeah i think for me
you know reflecting back on the
experience it has to be my communication
uh was the biggest was the biggest
growth area and from that i think it's
part of it's about knowing what you want
and part of it's about knowing
how to say things and how to communicate
your needs and desires to other people
in a way that's also respectful of their
own needs and desires um and there's
whole classes on that at stanford but um
that ended up being by far my i think
most important takeaway from school
you use this really fascinating word
rigorous like the rigorous kind of
approach to some of this like personal
like core skill development
how like what were some of the
structures that you would
say contributed to that rigor like how
would you kind of put words to that
well i think something that khalil was
just saying is is
part of i think what the business school
gets you to do is to reflect all the
time
and so you go and you take some action
and then you
think about how did that go and how do i
want to go differently in the future and
i think business school just really
ingrains that habit in you because for
one a lot of the teachers
are advocating that approach every week
every quarter some say every day you're
writing down
what you want to happen why you want it
to happen what are you going to do to
make it happen it's like this this huge
exercise and self-reflection
but you do it so much that i think it
starts to kind of
embed itself as a personal habit and
i've seen i've seen a lot of benefits um
from that just being more intentional
with how i spend my time and therefore
you see that you achieve more of the
things that you actually want to achieve
and you
don't spend time on the stuff that you
don't find as valuable
awesome song
how about yourself how how did you think
about leadership potential coming in
what did you want to develop or looking
back what was an area that you found
yourself growing a lot in
um yes so i think the first one that
comes to mind for me is um
before business school i was always in
these kind of high
stress situations and i had
effective but not great coping
mechanisms so i would like
you know
call a friend and like rant about work
or i would you know order a pizza or you
know just i had like all these like
systems about how like oh like i'm
having a hard time at work like this is
how i'm going to get through it and you
know those things work when you're 22 or
24
but one of the things i took away was
this idea of peer coaching and then
ultimately self coaching
and so there are classes that are
formally built around this but it's also
just
embedded in the dna of the entire you
know student class where in every class
formal or informal you're you end up you
know reaching out to your very talented
and smart and wise classmates for their
advice um asking them for
you know how they would approach a
problem what they would do
and then you know ultimately through
exercises like journaling like
reflection or you know there's even
classes where you send out a survey and
solicit feedback from people about your
own you know behaviors and your your
brand but you kind of develop this way
of like self-coaching and i think that's
something that i really appreciated now
that i've been out of gsb for a while
where now when i feel stressed i'm not
like you know door dashing a pizza all
the time i may be just taking a step
back and thinking like okay like why are
you stressed like what's happening like
is this you know what can you do or like
go for a walk or you you kind of learn
these um you know processes for for
handling things and i think that's
something that sounds silly but
um you know it's really taking very
[Music]
smart and hard-working people but
showing them how they can maybe be as
smart and as hard-working but in a
healthier and more sustainable way
yeah this idea of self-coaching i find
so fascinating can you do you have any
insights or like tips for folks out
there
about you know maybe something that you
learned along the way that others might
be able to adapt into kind of their
everyday
um yeah i i think one thing is um
this act of writing things down and
journaling to yourself
we live in such a fast digital age that
taking pen to paper can seem really
silly but
kind of like brian alluded to there is a
lot of power in sitting down whether
that's every day or every quarter or
whatever
and writing your own thoughts out and
kind of seeing it on paper and even just
going through that and
you know it's something that um whenever
i i can be consistent with it i do
notice a lot of um
benefit
um and so i think just journaling
self like written reflections goal
setting anything like that could be you
know i think is very powerful
nice
all right so we are getting close to the
end and i want to make sure we go to an
area that i find very near and dear to
my heart
the application process and so for
everyone out there as awesome as our
panelists are as awesome as our students
and alumni are they have no idea why
they were admitted and they probably
will never know
why they were admitted for all things
admissions related if you're curious
about the process definitely check in
with the mba admissions office or check
out our website there's a ton of great
information there
but that doesn't mean there might have
been some learnings talking about
journaling and self-reflection some
things kind of on this back end that you
might have wish that you did a little
bit more or haven't might be able to
share with people so maybe sean let's
start with you and i'm going to be
selfish and go around the circle here
sean khalil song and then brian so maybe
go into reverse chronological order
thinking back to when you were applying
to business school
any tips that you would give a younger
you
to help
you know make that process
as kind of approachable as possible
um
good question that's a good question
it's interesting because my my fiance is
actually she's in business school at
stanford right now um and
and i i really
can you can you repeat that please i
think you broke out for just a little
bit yeah of course sorry um so my fiance
is actually um at stanford right now
getting her mba she's class of 2022 so
she'll start her second year so while i
don't really remember my application
process i certainly remember hers
um because one was more recent two i was
more stressed out uh when you're when
you're kind of watching uh some someone
you love apply versus when you yourself
are applying and i think what something
that she did that i thought was really
helpful um
was outside of just talking to
students um in my class she tried to
reach out to a lot of alumni
that were relatively recently graduated
just to get a sense of the place because
she's been there obviously as a
significant other when i was a student
but it's very different this student
experience so she she was she was
hey sorry i think my headphones died
hopefully you can hear me um
it's probably finally to wrap this up
um i i think was most helpful was
talk to as many students as possible
current and otherwise recently graduated
um to just get a sense of what the place
and the culture is because i think
reflection of that in in your essay is
obviously important but more so
understanding that it's the right fit
for you um because i'm always amazed by
folks like will and the rest of
admissions in mission class how they're
able to stitch together a group of folks
who are so different that have so much
in common at the same time um so it that
that piece i think is critical just
understanding you know what stanford's
about what do you think you're going to
get out of it um and what the place is
like um and i think the easiest way to
do that is through conversations with
people who've been there yeah awesome
and for folks who might not know how to
start definitely i would also recommend
either checking out some of our webinars
because
there are times when you just aren't
able to connect at that individual level
maybe it's time resources network
the point of many of our summer series
is to provide an opportunity to learn
more about the student experience from
folks who just went through it we're
also recording many of these and posting
them online so as you're thinking about
some of these topics through the year if
you're thinking for the future you'll
have a repository of information that
you can always come back to um and we're
always here curious to know what you're
interested in and that helps me create
new events for you as well so thanks
sean
khalil um what about yourself tips for a
younger you
i i i think
the
the the part where i won't
provide that much insight into is like
the actual like gmat like you gotta like
crunch and
spin and that's the that was the worst
part for me uh i don't even if anyone
else on this panel has has good ways for
how to um
get through that uh please share but for
me that that was definitely the hardest
part the second hardest part ever was
okay that's done i got the score i want
that's out of the way um it's crafting
your story
um and
i think
that's incredibly important as you
you're gonna have
you're gonna apply to
say eight schools you have eight schools
there you
they all have different essays but like
ultimately you're telling the same story
and you're branding yourself without
that same story across different
environments so it's
figuring out and like spending the time
up front to figure out what your story
is
um
there's like a lot of self reflection
involved in figuring out like what's
most what matters most to you um
and
and then um
and then finding strings that tie that
like those passions to
to every like all of your different
activities all your different careers
yeah i promise you it's there and then
once you find it you can pull on
personal and professional experiences um
to really
to really tell that holistic story to to
the school you're applying to
well thank you so much
um i think my one advice would be um you
know i remember feeling so intimidated
and thinking that like
you know there's like 10 000 people that
apply and you know only so many get in
and so my advice be think about what you
would contribute to your class in
addition to just like
thinking about everything stanford has
to offer because the reality is once you
get there you are part of the dna and so
you will be helping your classmates and
bringing your lived experiences and so i
think that is something i didn't do
enough of i was so intimidated and just
you know
scared
but really think about if you were a
student you know at in this community
and at this place what are some of the
things that only you could bring to your
classmates or you could bring to the
experience for others and that i think
is a great way to kind of get your
wheels moving
both in terms of figuring out your own
story like khalil said but also
tying your lived experiences and your
dreams and aspirations with stanford and
kind of bringing those two things
together
and then brian taking us home
um
yeah i think i'll just say one thing
which is
what i noticed at school was it was
shocking to me how many people in my
class said they almost didn't apply to
stanford because they thought that they
wouldn't get in
and so i think my recommendation is if
you think
that the stanford program like excites
you
please do yourself the favor and apply
thank you
and to that effect
i encourage you if you haven't done so
already
continue this journey at
mystanford.mba you're able to do things
like create a personalized dashboard so
if you are in the process of applying
there's an application tracker so you'll
be able to know where in each step
you'll you are
if you're thinking about either this
year or the future we also launched
application week just this past month
and we saved the recordings again on our
gsb youtube channel including workshops
on how to start your story ways to
communicate your story in the written
format as well as what are different
ways of thinking about how do you
communicate it verbally whether that is
thinking about networking or even a
behavioral based interview how do you
prepare for that how are you able to
most effectively communicate who you are
what matters to you
what you've done and how you've done it
so thank you again everyone for joining
us today thank you to our panelists
hopefully we'll be able to interact much
more again in the future but until then
take care stay safe and have a wonderful
rest of the weekend everyone
[Music]